have you been watching hanabi's season
yeah she's amazing yeah I love her
do you've any frontrunners I like Jed I
feel like he's very calm
he's like playing it cool for now and I
like Garen who I think on any screen the
Dark Horse's though who like five or six
episodes in you know I felt like for
like seven episodes my first season I
did everyone was like who's Becca
so I feel like that's who Garrett is
this season
I always knew who Becca was though I do
have to ask you though I feel like you
are very open about your religious
beliefs and your virginity and that's
kind of how Hanna's been this season a
little bit what do you make of that and
what would you tell her I know she's
already shot but um I think it's just
like keep keep doing what you're doing
because I feel like she's done a great
job of just being very forward and like
expressing her feelings when she feels
them which I really like I think people
are becoming more comfortable with being
open about personal things about
themselves so I am excited to see
someone and her role like really
stepping up and doing it yeah it's funny
to say that because you told et that you
don't really want to be as open I know
right now why is that in one will you
know it's the right time to start
sharing more I don't know I think I just
kind of it'll happen when it happens
type thing you know I just am in a place
where I'm like keeping it personal but I
think that's why I respect Hanna so much
because it is like a very vulnerable
thing to be open in front of like so
many strangers and everyone has an
opinion it can be scary sometimes so
it's it's like a weird balance of
knowing when to share and like what to
share and I respect that you are doing
that as well but I do love your podcast
thank you is there anything aside from
the personal stuff that you'll never
Tonya um that you will never share on
that podcast um no I think at some point
I'll just share everything in anything
that's ever happened to me we because
because I feel like Tonya does that and
I feel like the roles are gonna not so
much reverse because I think she'll
always be that way but I think maybe I'm
gonna like step into that role of being
like no filter maybe I don't know but
you're thinking about it it's fine it's
time to like be like open and unfilled
certain there's also like a nice balance
of keeping some things private I have a
question for you though what's one of
your questions if Taylor slip comes by
okay I want to know he wanted them to be
fun so I'm just serious okay I want to
know why she named her cat Benjamin
Button oh I bet I know why that's why
and I want to know if it's a double
album and I want to know if it's gonna
be if there's any country on it what do
you do I think it's gonna be an album
with lots of collaboration and I think
there's gonna be country elements we
don't meet up we would like Taylor but
we don't need Taylor cuz the Becca's
here I'm Taylor spokesperson yeah I love
it thank you so much you're the best
[Music]